congratulations obviously we're
celebrating 100 years and saved the
children a cause so near and dear to you
I mean it goes without saying between
your career and your businesses of
course life at home as a mother you're
so busy why has it been so important for
you to despite your hectic like you
still dedicate so much of yourself to
this cause well I don't know if when I
started working for save 11 a year 11
years ago that I would I did I don't
know that I meant to spend as much time
with them as I do the thing is when you
are lucky enough to get to see a problem
up close and for me that is poverty in
rural America and when you're lucky
enough to get to go into people's homes
to go to the kids school to see their
neighborhoods to see and understand what
they're up against and then you see a
solution and you see hope and optimism
if there is nothing that is more of a
driver than that cloud shouldn't really
have a choice I have to do it's
life-changing yeah how would you say
being a mother and having your children
in your life have influenced not just
your support of this foundation and
organization but influence your outlook
on the world
kids and they're funny and smarten you
know I think they're awesome but other
than that you have to you have to
maintain a sense of humor about yourself
you have to be reach out and be part of
a community you can trace them by
yourself and yeah I just say you know
they change you wholly and completely
and not at all so I just um you know I'm
lucky to have them sometimes I wonder if
we have them to thank for you being on
Instagram because you really are showing
that fun goofy side on the ground
Halloween of course is around the corner
does it get easier or harder that the
older the kids get deciding on what
costumes are gonna do and and are you
dying like do a group themed with them
and they're like mom no we've had our
time
remember one year when I talk my girls
into both dressing up his pigs and they
were so cute and now they were doing and
no mom oh my gosh no so you know yeah
it's harder but they're gonna be cute
whatever they are
[Music]